the latest CBS News poll finds
Republicans are less likely to wear a
mask in public than Democrats let's take
a look at these numbers they show that
more Republicans 59% described it as a
personal choice while 76% of Democrats
say it is a public health responsibility
our poll also found 62% of Americans
think the u.s. is dealing badly with the
coronavirus and we should note that
nearly all health officials nearly all
health officials recommend wearing a
mask in public it'll keep reports though
on the mixed messages coming from
America's leaders if your local
officials in consultation with the state
are directing you to wear a mask we
encourage everyone to wear a mask
despite vice president pence showing
support for masks on Sunday in an
interview taped Saturday with Face the
Nation he said that he and President
Trump believe is up to local officials
to set the rules we've made it clear
that we want to defer to governor's we
want to defer to local officials the
patchwork of decisions made by state
officials to stretch beyond masks to
testing and reopening and it's leading
to mixed outcomes if I could go back and
redo anything it probably would have
been to slow down the opening of bars we
used science and we wouldn't open any
region unless they hit certain metrics
science shows when people wear masks the
virus doesn't transmit as easily but
across the country there's confusion as
mayor's county leaders and governors all
set different examples in New Jersey
where masks are required in most public
places Democratic governor Phil Murphy
publicly shames constituents on how to
wear one but in Arkansas Republican
governor ASA Hutchinson says a statewide
mandate would be difficult we're not
going to pass a mandate that is
unenforceable from the beginning of the
pandemic mr. Trump has shunned masks but
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden regularly appears in public
wearing a mask he says he'd make it a
national standard one thing we do know
these masks make a gigantic difference
the mixed messages are causing angry
confrontations nationwide like at this
California supermarket on Friday where a
woman refused to wear one saying she had
breathing problems
dr. William Schaffner as a professor of
infectious diseases
this virus knows no political
affiliation it will infect you whether
you're blue red or green vice-president
pence has cancelled campaign appearances
for later this week in Arizona and
Florida but still plans to make official
visits to those states to meet with
their Republican governors the Biden
campaign has no plans to hold
large-scale rallies until they say
public health officials say it's safe to
do so
Anthony ed O'Keefe thank you ad